hi honey
ugly God DC become desperate clams what
these videos I mean not a hot one in the
bunch you got to go all the way to
Annapolis to find any place this is way
too much traffic way more than normal
these people wandering around the only
no tax tax this tax that is that we
already did this was everyone still
complaining about so many hippies hey
excuse me you old Aunt Bea you're wrong
you're totally wrong and you're totally
self-involved this is perfect
stop the car unbelievable
look at these guys where's your
husband's where's your husband's you
shouldn't be free it's a weekend it's
laundry time it's laundry time
[Music]
[Applause]
nah
the secrecy mr. president and release
your own you don't know what I'm going
to release but it's going to be a full
release when I do it
haven't you ever been to a massage
parlor a wonderful little girl you want
to take a picture with me let's just do
it and then be done okay right that okay
that could knocking well today across
the country Americans are calling
look up example dogs are busted
I know okay
oh you need to get rid of these people
take out the old engine oil progressive
who fun for an America where we have an
equal take and happy on the frontlines
exotica stops okay to the dinner and
skin cream egg excuse me you idiot and
here everybody
[Applause]
thank you so much
sorry wonderful table such a large crowd
from brain so great and so many of you
support me and you hear the screaming
and I'm so pleased is the wind dying
down now what's a big deal about
releasing my caricature first off I
claim Ivanka as three dependents my
daughter my mother and my wife
so what I owe 50 million dollars to
Deutsche Bank who cares okay that
probably no but what you don't know is I
know where all the Nazi gold
I just because I have dirty ties to
Azerbaijan I have so many crises well if
you don't know in my tax returns is I'd
the original uncut David Hasselhoff
video of good eating a burger hot cook
Troy remember that remember that so we
want to release the tax returns we can
do it voice let's get the Texas where
are they actually I'm not tomorrow I'll
go with today so we want these taxes and
we're going to release them and I want
you to know that everyone can look at
them now and we're all either right let
me some boy tactic
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm co-chairing distracted but I'm not
sure added with Yiddish brocoli
bring to make America great again
yeah